لا تزال قصه اطفال الامازون مشاهدين الذين
اتاهوا اربعين يوما متفاعلا هذه المره
بحمله كبيره للعثور على من على كلب لعب
دورا بارزا في عمليه العثور عليهم بطل
عمليه العثور هذا الكلب هو عثر عليهم لكنه
ضاع في الغابه الكولومبيه الموضوع كبير
لدرجه ان رئيس الدوله اصدر تعليمات لفرق
البحث بان لا يعودوا من دون هذا الكلب اكد
الجيش في تغريده ان عمليات البحث جاري عن
الكلب الذي يدعى ويلسون وان عناصره لن
يتخلوا عن زميل الميدان كما انتشرت حمله
دعم ويلسون عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لدعم الكلب المفقود
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات